很多做短线的朋友经常跟我抱怨说
做短线技术战法以及技术指标没有用
具有严正的滞后性
不能够及时的反映出实时的行情走势
确实咱们做短线理想的状态是进场急斩
在短时间内要求兑现的及时性
而很多朋友明明做的是超短
却看的是日K线
做波段却每天盯着分时走势
所以导致结果不理想
这就是操作目标周期与技术指标不匹配所造成的
比如说做超短
超短一般不会超过三天
很多朋友参考的却是日K线
一天就只有一根K线
参考的均线也至少是五天均线
代表的就是五天的平均成本
那去参考做超短
这中间就会存在一个时间差
所以会滞后
因此想要做好超短
建议大家从日K线切换到60分钟级别的K线
大家好
我是你们的老朋友
点个赞
今天就给大家带来60分钟K线超短操作法
首先想要做好超短
我们先要把日K线切换到60分钟周期的K线图
然后再调出5小时15小时60小时均线
做超短啊
我们就从根本上去出发
用超短所匹配的技术指标
要知道一天的交易时间是四个小时
那么去看60分钟K线图的话
一天就有四根K线
那参考的这三根均线
五小时均线比一天多一个小时
最长周期的60小时均线相当于半个月
那么这样啊
就从短到长的均线设置
能够把每天的波动都包括进去
这个时候可能有的朋友会问
小周期那么多
为什么要选择60分钟K线图呢
因为60分钟K线图既有稳定性
又能够提前做预判
一旦形成趋势
60分钟K线图大概率能够持续10个小时左右
跟日K线相比的话
60分钟K线图能够更早的察觉日线破位的风险
与更短的周期
比如5分钟K线15分钟K线去相比的话60分钟K线图会更加的稳定所以做超短60分钟K线图最为合适
那看60分钟K线图的话
具体如何去进场离场呢
我们先来看操作核心要点
等一下我还会结合石盘K线
和大家一点一点详细讲解清楚
我们来看进场点
前提是60小时均线走平或者是倾斜向上
当满足这个前提条件之后
当60分钟K线放量突破60小时均线
便可以直接进场
还有一种前提条件还是一样
60小时均线走平或者是倾斜向上
K线已经在60小时均线上方运行
当K线回踩60小时均线不破
也是一个较好的进场时机
离场点的话也有两个
当5小时均线下穿15小时均线形成死差
那么就可以减仓离场
当K线跌破60小时均线
那么有多快跑多快
听到这里可能还有很多朋友没有听明白
那具体的话
咱们还是通过实行K线来做详细的讲解
就比如这个标的
先我们要点左上角的60分钟点一下
切换到60分钟K线
然后我们点均线点设置
修改指标参数
把均线设置成5小时
15小时
以及60小时
然后把其他的均线全部删掉
然后点确认
这个时候我们的看盘软件上面
就会显示三根均线
分别是5小时
15小时
以及60小时均线
那具体咱们如何操作呢
我们把它缩小来看一下
首先我们的前提条件是
这一根60小时的均线
它要走平
或者是微微倾斜向上
那我们才能够去操作
像这根60小时均线往下走的时候
说明它是处于下降的一个趋势
那我们去操作的话
它的成根率就会很低
比如说你在这个地方你去进场的话
算你进场最低点
它在这里第二天马上就被套牢
因为它是60分钟K线
它一天的话有四根K线
这天进场
一天两天三天四天
那么隔天的话就很容易被套牢
直接往下走
我们只有当这根60均线走平
或者是倾斜向上的时候咱们再去操作这样子超短的一个操作成根概率才会更高才能够形成买入急斩的一个状态
比如说啊
像这个位置
我们把它放大来看一下
我们放大之后可以看到啊
这个位置60小时均线已经开始处于一个走平的状态
这个时候它的一个K线
它是放量突破了60小时均线
那么这个时候啊
便可以大胆的去进场
进场之后我们可以看到
它是迎来了一段大幅度的拉伸行情
拉伸之后我们可以看到
在这个地方它的一个五小时均线
下穿15小时均线形成死差
那么这一天就可以进行一个减餐或者是离场
因为我们做的是超短嘛
进场即展
那么就符合咱们超短的一个目标
对吧
那么这里死差的话
是可以选择减餐或者是直接离场
那么像后续向60小时均线
处于一个倾斜向上
也就是趋势向上的一个状态
那么当5小时均线上穿15小时均线形成金叉
像这个位置形成金叉
那么这点也是一个加仓进场点
进场之后
它也是迎来了立即的拉伸行情
拉伸之后
在这个地方
5小时均线下穿15小时均线形成死叉
那么在这一天就可以选择离场
离场之后
它也是迎来了一段大幅度的调整行情
调整之后
它的60小时均线
它还是倾斜向上的
看到没有
那么在这个地方
它是放量突破了60小时均线
那么在这一天就可以果断的进场
进场之后
我们可以看到
它也是立马就迎来了拉伸行情
我们再缩小
再看一下它后续的一个行情
我们可以看到
在这一天进场之后
它也是迎来了一波大幅度的拉伸行情
然后在这个地方
它是5小时均线下穿15小时均线形成死差
那么这一天是可以减餐或者是离场
之后我们可以看到
它K线回踩这根60小时均线不破
那么这一天也是一个加餐进场的好时机
进场之后我们可以看到
它迎来了一波大幅度的拉伸行情
当然进场之后
像这里5小时均线下穿15小时均线形成死差
也是可以减餐
包括这个地方
它是回踩60小时均线不破那么这点又是一个加仓进场的好时机进场之后它也是立马就拉伸对吧那么像后续5小时下船15小时均线形成死仓
那么这一天啊
也是要减仓或者是离仓
那像后期K线
它是跌破了60小时均线
那么这一天啊
有多快就要跑多快
后续的话就是持续的调整
我们再来看这个标的
也是一样
我们首先要看的
就是60小时均线
它要走平
或者是倾斜向上
我们才能够去操作
像这个地方
它的均线往下
已经出现了拐头走平的一个迹象
然后在这一天
它是出现了K线
突破了60小时均线
并且它下方是一个泛量的状态
那么这一天的话
是可以去进场
进场之后
也是立马迎来了一个拉伸行情
但是拉伸之后
我们可以看到
它紧接着就迎来了一个五小时下船
15小时均线形成时差
那么这一天咱们就要果断的去离场
可能很多朋友会认为
这一段它的一个涨幅并不大
要知道我们做的是超短
能够进场急涨
也能够及时的兑现
这就是超短的一个精髓所在
我们再往后看
这一个60小时均线
它也是持续的走平
对吧
那么这一天他是突破了60小时均线
并且下方呈现一个放量的状态
那么这一天作为超短也是可以进场
进场之后这一天形成死差
那么这一天就要离场或者是减仓
对吧
后续他是再一次突破了60小时均线
并且下方也是放量
那么这一天可以果断的进场
进场之后也是立马迎来了一波大幅度的拉伸行情
拉伸之后这一天形成死差
那么这一天就要果断的离场
那么我们就能够及时的规避掉
这一波大幅度的调整
好了我就不一一去验证了
大家也可以切换60分钟K线去做复盘验证
60分钟K线对超短的操作来说会更为匹配
不仅准确度高还能达到及时性
今天的话就先到这里
还有不明白的可以评论留言
如果说对你有所启发
不妨点个赞加关注
你方便查看我更多使用操作技巧
别忘了再来一波666支持一下
咱们下期再见